you told me this was gonna be a simple
extraction they were waiting for me what
was waiting for me was barely human it
tore the back off my car
grow a spine so low
this is the most dangerous town human
artistry
we recently discovered an international
criminal organization with an atom bomb
we have no choice but to work together
on this
America teaming up with Russia doesn't
summer friendly we'll leave you two to
get acquainted
I'll let you tag along but it's in and
out no mess and we both forget about in
the morning this is not the Russian way
any water investigates Victoria
Vinciguerra they will send an army to
stop us we must give them an appropriate
welcome he's better for the mission that
we get to know each other a little bit
more intimately means I like my woman
strong hey Russell
special agent you are not having a very
special day are you
yeah so sorry I can't stay to finish you
off myself
your tracker is not sending a signal do
you want to check it be my guest
what are you doing down there try not to
get lost I'll turn it on now finish this
things could get a little messy
absolutely head working with you parent
with a terrible spy cowboy
oh and you have a new code name code
name uncle
you
you